DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: So hi, and
welcome to the studio today.
I'm David, and I'm here in
India for my very first visit.
I'm really pleased to be here.
It's a beautiful
country, and I've
enjoyed meeting with
all of the developers
and all the startups
over the last few days.
We join you today from the
newest studio in the Google
Developers Live family, the
studio here in Hyderabad.
Brand new, and this is the first
show to be recorded from it.
I'm here today with Uttam,
the regional lead for India.
Happy to have you on board.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Thank you.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN:
We're here today
to talk about the DevFests.
DevFests are a great
series of events
that we're right in
the middle of now.
So Uttam, a couple
of years ago, Google
used to run a series of
events in a handful of cities
around the world.
What led to the
creation of DevFests?
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Yeah,
David, as you rightly said,
a couple of years ago
Google was running
events, Google Developers
[? Days ?] and DevFests.
These events were across
multiple cities in the world.
So one of the things
with these events
is we are only able to touch
those many places because we
have constraints on
Google [? Spot ?]
that we can reach out to.
And around a couple of
months after I joined,
one of the things that we saw
from the community coming up
is there was an interest of
Google Developer Groups going
out and running larger events.
We saw pilots in India,
similar events in Japan,
places in Europe.
And these were
community-run large events.
So when we saw these
kind of events coming up,
we did understand
that this is something
that community is interested
in, running larger events.
Around Google I/O last year,
we had the big GDG summit
in Mountan View.
We shared this idea
with the community,
in which Google Developer Groups
run events called DevFests.
And the response that
we got was terrific,
so this has been the idea.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: Very cool.
Yeah, it's really
exciting that communities
want to run their own
events, and put it together,
and arrange for
all the speakers.
Very exciting.
So last year was the first year.
It was the pilot year.
And yet I would say
that the results from it
were much bigger than any
pilot that I ever anticipated.
How many events did
we have last year?
UTTAM TRIPATHI: So last year
we had close to 75 events.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: 75, yeah?
UTTAM TRIPATHI:
Yeah, which was way
above the quota we anticipated.
We were expecting maybe
a couple of dozen.
Because that was the
number we had with the GDG
and DevFests back in the day.
But as you rightly
said, the community
was really enthusiastic.
And they wanted to take these
events to their chapters,
and to their regions.
So that was a big
achievement in terms
of what the community achieved.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah,
no, that's really awesome.
It was shocking to me
the first few times I
was talking to Uttam and
the registrations were just
coming in.
It was so exciting to see
all of our GDG communities
wanting to do their own events.
And this year is even
bigger, isn't it?
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Yeah,
this year is even bigger.
So at Google I/O
this year, when we
had all of the Developer
Group organizers
from across the world
at the Mountain View,
we talked about DevFests 2013.
And we shared the
dates over the season,
and the response was much,
much more than last year.
So we have committed to
support more than 150 events
across the globe, which is
more than double than what
we had last year.
And this year, we are
touching over 60 countries,
touching close to
30,000 developers.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN:
That is extremely impressive.
That is a massive
community, and it's all
thanks to our wonderful
developers around the world.
Just think, a program that,
a couple of years ago,
was just a spark in
your imagination now
touches over 30,000 developers.
Very impressive.
So tell me about
this particular year.
We've divided it
into two seasons?
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Yeah, so this
year, we have two seasons.
Season one was mid of September
till the end of September,
a couple of weeks there.
And now we are in the
middle of season two.
We've started on
13th of October,
which will go until
10th of November.
So season two will
probably see a lot
of events in Europe,
Africa, and a few of them
in the Middle East.
There will be a handful of them
in Southeast Asia and India,
but most of the Asia
events were in season one.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN:
Right, in season one.
Now, I also know
that this year, we
piloted another type of DevFest.
It was called DevFest
W. Can you tell me
a little bit about that?
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Yeah,
that's one, again,
an interesting
experiment that we
did in partnership
with the community.
So in February,
March this year, we
had a series of
events called DevFest
W. It's for DevFest Women.
These were primarily
events to which
we wanted to increase diversity
in our developer groups.
And again, the idea
was to make sure
that we have strong and
solid developer content being
discussed at these events.
At the same time, encouraging
more women to come up,
more diversity at these events.
And almost all of these events
had at least one lady organizer
managing the event, and
a lot of speaker sessions
were delivered by
ladies as well.
So that was a big push in
terms of increasing diversity
in our user groups.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN:
That's really exciting.
I know I was talking a couple
nights ago with some ladies who
had run DevFest W
events here in India.
And just the level
of their skill,
the level of their passion,
was just so refreshing to me.
I really enjoyed
seeing all the women
around the world very
interested in joining up
in engineering and starting
really awesome projects.
So let's talk about
one of these events.
Tell me about the format.
Typically, it's a
series of lectures
given by community members?
UTTAM TRIPATHI: So the format
is each GDG organizer decides
what's the best for their event.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN:
So they are very
custom to each
area of the world.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Exactly.
That's the idea, because we
have understood that organizers
understand what's
best for their region,
and we let them do that.
The most popular format
are speaker sessions,
because this is traditionally
the way of sharing knowledge
with the developers.
So of course, almost all of
the DevFests do have speaker
sessions as one of
the primary things,
in which they talk about
multiple Google technologies,
ranging from Android, App
Engine, cloud stuff, Google+,
Chrome, HTML5, and a lot of
other open source technologies
are being discussed because
the communities are open and we
like that way.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: Very cool.
In addition to
these talks, I know
I was talking to some
folks the other night--
again, here in India--
and they were excited
that there were
other parts of these,
too-- a bunch of hands-on
type of sessions?
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Yeah,
almost half of the DevFests
also have a hands-on
component to it,
which can be either a
code lab or a hackathon,
in which you implement,
or you put to test,
what you just learned
to the speaker sessions.
So code labs is one
of the popular formats
in which there's an
instructor who leads a class.
And they go through some
of the code examples.
And then, some of
the other cases, you
have hackathons, which
culminates into pitches
by the developers on
what they have built.
So these are the
components of these events.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: Very cool.
And a lot of this content I
know was developed by Google,
and distributed to the
various DevFest organizers.
But a significant
percentage of it
was developed by the organizers
and by the speakers themselves.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Exactly.
That's completely right.
So as you said,
from Google side,
we did create some
of the content
and gave it to the
organizers, because almost 80%
of the speaker
sessions last year,
DevFests, were by the community.
So we understood that
community organizers
are coming up and speaking.
At the same, we
wanted to help them
as much as possible through
content and stuff like that.
But in a lot of other
cases, a lot of content
was being generated by the
community speakers themselves.
So this again.
The way DevFests
are being run is
a lot of community initiatives.
Communities are
really owning it.
And we are more
in a support role
in terms of what we can do.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: Very cool.
So I was able to listen
to a number of sessions.
And all of them were awesome.
All of them had excellent
quality speakers.
The content was just
very compelling.
I learned a tremendous amount.
What excited me also was
the variety of content.
There were deep
dives about products.
There were introductions
to products.
They were topics on
marketing, on taking your idea
into a business, and pretty
much everything in between.
What were some of the sessions
that stood out to you?
UTTAM TRIPATHI: So
some of the sessions
that are really
popular-- of course,
Android is a popular technology.
But some of the
sessions that we saw
happening across
multiple DevFests
is things like how do you
improve your app quality.
With so many apps now on
Play Store, what really makes
a difference is the
quality of your app,
and the kind of ratings
that you can generate.
So some of the sessions around
following best practices,
both in terms of the UI, and
getting high quality reviews
for your app was one of
the popular sessions.
The other thing that was
discussed multiple times
is using more than
one Google technology
in a particular product.
For example, you
build an Android app,
with a backend on App Engine,
and you put in Google+ sign
in to it, which enables
you to get more installs,
more downloads, and
things like that.
So these were some of
the popular sessions
that were at DevFests.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: Very cool.
And so a lot of the communities
have taped their sessions.
And over the next few months,
we'll be making as many
of these as we can
available online
so that any of you who
weren't able to attend
a DevFest in person
will still be
able to enjoy some
of the great content.
So if someone wants
to participate
in one of the remaining DevFests
of the second season this year,
how can they do it?
UTTAM TRIPATHI: So all
the DevFest information
is at developers.google.com.
As soon as you go
to the page, you'll
see a campaign link
there which encourages
you to join a DevFest near you.
You either click
on that campaign,
or you can directly
go to the URL
developers.google.com/events/devfest.
That's where the whole calendar
of this year's DevFest season
is put up.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: Cool.
So next year we hope there
are even more events.
Let's say somebody wants to
start their own event next year
in a city that we didn't
have it at this year.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Yeah,
so DevFest, in the way
that it's running
right now is being
run by Google Developer Groups.
So if you cannot find
a DevFest near you,
and you're interested
to run one,
I think the best bet is just
get involved with the Google
Developer Group program and
start a chapter in your region.
The way to do that is go to
developers.google.com/groups,
which has all the
program information.
It has a form, a
very short form.
Just fill in that and send it.
Someone from our team
will get back to you
and will set you up
for starting a chapter.
That would be the first step
for running a DevFest next year.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: Sounds great.
So we have GDGs
all over the world.
We have DevFests
There's probably one near
you, but like Uttam said,
if there's not, we
encourage you to start one.
We'd love to have Google
Developer Groups everywhere
and to have as much
involvement as possible.
So the DevFest season so
far has been incredible.
It's been inspiring to me to
watch the community talks,
to watch the level of
passion and engagement.
I'm looking forward to the rest
of the events in season two.
I'm looking forward to
an even better 2014.
So I appreciate all the help of
the communities that run this.
And I want to thank
Uttam for his time today.
UTTAM TRIPATHI:
Thanks, thanks David.
Thanks to all the GDG
organizers for running
this awesome series
of DevFests this year.
And I'm sure next year
will be even grand.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: Cool.
Thank you.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Thank a lot.